you tell them when to take the orders
right that's right it's people that over
the eastern one course I think it was so
it's who thing that we might get that's
what we would like to order a soon Sam
was there watching start some a cause
would be served and yet another all have
taken yeah you wouldn't only have hurt
me in the restaurant know once would do
so I heard that they want to take her
and let alone just see it a little bit
and also the tip of that the Diamonds
been told by the kitchen so they're
running less they can't do anything
unless the kitchen says so which is just
crazy they need to function
control freak snook control freak is
trying to stay focused on the story it
is because you're not in the dining room
sets your teeth control freak
alright I've never seen anything so
stupid in all my life chefs don't tell
waiters when to take an order that's the
responsibility of the dining room to the
chef he's trying to control as well to
give control back to the front of house
I can see a solution if you'd like it
different I can't grandson Jake is on
top of things
yeah well that would you be better done
you see nose has not been disparaging to
run but you seem to know what you're
doing it sort of I wanted to do it mine
in his way and she's got a little he
seemed to know yeah I'm gonna sell this
be a lot of smooth Oh in fact something
running here the food was actually
delicious
I think the only thing that wasn't
really I just standard was the
disservice it was worth away that that's
that's the good thing
oh [ __ ] that my diners have no
complaints about the food because the
cooking is inspiring but Graham is
tripping up the service and he has to
understand this ok it's the issue
unfortunately ok the service is nowhere
near to the standard of food you left
two tables you know sat there for over
an hour before we even took their order
and the dining room felt short-staffed
Food Centre the same table twice that
starts already gone
Jackie across the two hours you didn't
give me the impression that you were
enjoying it as much as she does
are you a hundred percent happy running
that dyeing room on a normal day yes I
don't normal day but today I was a bit
you know panicking
yeah J you were the one shining light
out there and why you're not at the helm
relieving the pressure from your mother
and working closely with your father
I'll never know you've sort of castrated
the dyeing room because you're
controlling them you've got to cut some
of the control freak in you and allow
them to do their job and you'll be
surprised at the results I'm telling you
because I want this place to really
succeed in this competition why because
the food is beautiful well done
it's like any any criticism you you take
it on boarding it felt very throw endure
and react so I mean listen listen food
for full